due to a massive scheduling error there  was one final act that had to follow  Beyonce at Coachella did you know that  there was an act that had to go on after  Beyonce gave the performance of the  history of civilization right seriously  the greatest performance ever and then  they sent someone else out there we have  the footage because I have to you have  to take a look at this take a look give  it up again for Beyonce now believe it  or not we do have one more act for you  tonight a war welcome please for Cristal  I only have eyes for the likes of you I  do  oh look  [Applause]  we both agree the time wasn't right yeah  keep throwing  [Applause]  you